dans l'actualité culturelle hier le
musée départemental mauricedenis situé à
Saint-Germain en lait et le musée
d'orset ont signé une convention de
partenariat scientifique alors Gabriel
Gontier vous étiez sur place ça
représente quoi cette convention et bien
cette signature grégoryi elleofficialise
le lien qui unit les deux musées alors
depuis de nombreuses années car depuis
l'ouverture du musée départemental
Maurice deis cétait en 1980 les deux
institutions collaborent ensemble
l'objectif avec cette signature c'est
donc d'inscrire et de faire perdurer ce
lien et ce partenariat il va permettre
plusieurs choses notamment davantage de
prêt entre le les musées ce qui va
contribuer à l'enrichissement des
collections du musée Maurice Denis on a
interrogé le président du musée d'Orsay
sur cette collaboration ce partenariat
entre le musée d'Orsay et le musée
Maurice Denis est un une alliance pour
que le musée d'Orsay puisse apporter ses
son concours non seulement par des prêts
d'œuvre des dépôts mais aussi un soutien
sur scientifique pour les projets de
publication les projets d'exposition et
puis tout ce qui peut se se présenter à
l'avenir pour renforcer le le prestige
et l'attractivité du musée Maurice Denis
alors ce partenariat il a été signé pour
5 ans il s'inscrit également dans la
volonté du musée d'orset de développer
des coopérations en dehors de Paris et
cette signature devrait permettre
également de mieux connaître ce musée
Maurice Denis et aussi ses collections
oui si le musée départemental est bien
inscrit dans le territoire des ivelines
depuis de nombreuses années les œuvres
de l'artiste yvelinois restent encore
mal connu ce partenariat va permettre
plus de visibilité au musée c'est ce que
nous explique le président du
Département Pierre Bédier nous allons
pouvoir grâce euh à ce partenariat
pouvoir mieux faire connaître ce musée
qui souffre d'un déficit de
communication parce que il est
absolument
extraordinaire le lieu est magique
l'œuvre de Maurice Denis est d'une d'une
richesse d'un foisonnement exceptionnel
et euh donc ça va être une aide à la
communication et puis ça va être une
aide à l'approfondissement de la
connaissance de l'œuvre à la démarche
scientifique bon vous l'avez compris les
œuvres de Maurice Denis ont encore de
belles années devant elle une bonne
nouvelle pour le patrimoine yvelinois
car la grande majorité d'étoiles de
l'artiste ont été peintes dans les
ivlines dans son atelier de
Saint-Germain enlay merci à Gabriel